hello everyone and welcome uh to another
game on leeches I'm gonna play uh five
plus zero Blitz game uh usually I've
played three plus zero you guys said
that I should up at the five plus zero
uh to make
um okay to not make every game about uh
maybe uh going going into time trouble
and blundering so let's try uh five plus
zero uh uh our opponent is uh come in a
one or Commando uh and he goes for the
Sicilian all right we're gonna play
Knight F3 he's going for E6 and we're
gonna just challenge it with a standard
D4 he goes Knight F6 uh challenges the
pawn uh Knight to C3 pretty much a must
I usually play C4 if he doesn't attack
the Knight but now that he does okay
um this is a line I've studied a long
long time ago and there's a you know
there's a funny E5 line here uh that I
don't remember how to play but maybe
it'll it'll come back to me now Queen G4
uh puts pressure on the G5 okay now he
confused me thoroughly
uh I have to remember what's the point
of it all
um but I'm sure he's gonna he's gonna
help me remember yeah maybe if I capture
he goes back he goes Queen A5
looks um
definitely looks like something
okay
okay so best best for him to just show
it to me no no okay huh
G5 interesting
let's go here not be five
now I'm sort of eyeing this D6 square
but also defending my C3 Knight twice if
he plays A6 I might even consider a move
like Knight to D6 check uh but I don't
know
I've never seen this position so G5 uh
yeah okay Queen A5 obviously
uh and once he takes I can even take
with the Knight I'm guessing
such a weird position such a weird
position all right I can play a30
um
it's really weird
really weird stuff here
can't wait to look at the devaluation
after after the game all right so
I I'm having a hard time
you know buying this
what if I just take here
what is his plan okay he's obviously
going to take my Rook
but then I give a check
are you telling me that it is possible
for him to survive this
is it possible to survive this
and now I give a check and he can play
this
how exactly does that work
check
yeah I think he overdid it a little bit
Maybe
I mean okay he's still
he's still in the game because
is there a way is there a better way to
to play this
I want to capture the Knight obviously
but maybe there's like something
Queen E3 looks super scary Queen E3
looks really scary threatening Queen C5
and then
yeah maybe that maybe that
I don't see a way for him to okay if I
go here he goes maybe Knights of D5 and
then a nice check here he can go Knight
uh the C6 so he stops that yeah I don't
think there's a better move than
capturing
okay
so he he can obviously do that
now do I invite him to capture here or
do I just play this and then allow
captures here
yeah it seems I'm gonna have to do it
like this
okay
all right
my king is in a bit of a weird uh
Square here but uh
you know nothing
nothing too
too bad
I'm I'm hoping
okay
he can of course play that let's put our
King here
it's always nice to put a king uh so far
away from the Knight
and uh
yeah I mean if we can get our Queen
their game should be should be
should be fine
or if I can get my Bishop into the game
with some sort of a check
would also be fine yeah okay he's gonna
play that
naturally uh let's play G4 oh he wants
this for his uh for his Queen
yeah let's play
how to do this how to do this
hmm
yeah I think we can actually no we can
yeah he gives a check and then our
Bishop is is gone
uh this is really weird
flip Queen F3
something like this
okay so he will take it I don't
really think that was the way to go but
oh yeah I can't take he can go there
which is pretty bad how does he stop
here how does he stop this
wow
oh this will be this will be so much fun
looking
um
looking at afterwards
okay so obviously he wants to stop a
mate uh but can he do it that's the
question if I play Bishop E3 is there a
move that prevents mate he can play some
checks but I don't think he can yeah I
can play Queen check I'm just going to
move the king and that's pretty much it
oh he can play that okay so we're gonna
take it here
uh offer the full rook and
meet him next
what did he play no he resigned alright
so he resigned okay so very nicely done
uh let me just quickly Analyze This to
see uh
after that crucial position Bishop G5
okay I played this yeah okay that's the
line that okay Queen G4 I remember the
line correctly G5 ah G5 actually
blunders the game and I remember that on
most lines Queen to G3 was a move I just
didn't think that it was also uh the
move in in this G file a G5 line I I
knew that Queen G3
uh was the the way to go in in other
lines but I thought that he prepared the
G5 specifically in order to counter
Queen G3 but okay Knight the B5 the move
I played okay also seems like it's
winning
uh and here okay so here just Queen G5
is is enough
Queen G5 is enough because after a
knight captures on C3 big captors
uh you obviously can't capture yeah
after King to D1 the problem is uh again
the same thing the the problem is
getting checkmated so yeah you have to
know this in order to play it but okay
here okay I played it well the the
offering of The Rook was fine being
captors and G5 did I miss anything
spectacular
Bishop okay so here okay queen king D1
was the way to go to Bishop D2 okay
Knight to C6 yeah only moves F4 I4 was a
blunder
F4 gives the game away uh ah I was oh I
was looking for Waste uh the you know
Focus king and queen but the bishop to
C3 was a nice wave of course he doesn't
give up the queen he moves the queen but
then I get to develop okay so F4 kind of
blunders the game and he took it and now
it's pretty much uh
not as winning I played King here and
now he's completely winning after Queen
to D1 but he doesn't play it and now
he's getting checkmated yeah after Queen
to D1 the point is that after
yeah of course I played this he has
Knight D4 check I play here and now he
captures yakia that was a pretty bad
Miss by both of us uh but after this
yeah now it's just a game over Queen C5
uh yeah I can also play this check first
I played this uh sort of makes it a
little bit weird but what are you gonna
do okay so uh nicely played and uh yeah
this is also one of the lines that you
have to know if you face the the E6
Sicilian like sort of this you know it's
uh it looks scary but it's nothing
spectacular also King to Faith you as
you can see here the engine's suggesting
a fine move but yeah
so not bad uh but I I did miss that
terrible terrible move here yeah after
not going for this yeah he had Quinta D1
here absolutely crushing uh but that's
Blitz chess uh everyone will miss
something so you know uh it was him who
missed uh and uh I I'm the one who's
Triumph in this game uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the of the really strong
players but also uh playing a game uh
here and then uh here and there you know
in order for us to learn something I'm
gonna try and make the next game with me
playing uh something like the Sicilian
with black uh just to see uh how it goes
uh so yeah see you soon